This episode is sponsored by Fabulous, the #1 self care app that helps you start building better habits.
The first 100 people who click on the link
in the description will get 25% off a Fabulous subscription.
The little ciliate you see swimming through
the field of debris on your screen right now has a fun name.
It’s called Rhinothrix porculus.
The first part of the name, Rhinothrix, combines
the Greek words “rhino”, for nose,
and “thrix”, for hair.
No, the name is not an ode to nose hair.
Rather, the name is a reference to the hair-like
cilia around the organism, and the fact that
up there at one end, is what
looks like a teeny tiny nose.
The second part of the organism’s name,
”porculus”, translates to pig.
And that makes sense because Rhinothrix porculus
likes to live in mud.
This little organism belongs to the family
Spathidiidae, though we’ll just call them
by their common name Spathidiids.
Spathidiids are found in freshwater and marine
habitats, but they’re also often found in soil.
And some time ago, James, our master of microscopes,
received 60 soil samples from a far away forest
on the eastern edge of Poland, storing them
in plastic bottles in his bathroom.
And every so often, like a force of nature
gathering over a woodland, James adds water
to those samples and watches the organisms
go wild.
And wild do they go.
This is a recording of one of their feeding
frenzies, which we think involves a horde
of Spathidiids wreaking havoc on a population
of ciliates called colpodids.
It’s chaos in microbial form and if you’re
having trouble making out exactly what’s
going on, don’t worry, that’s kind of
the Spathidiid experience for you.
The family Spathidiidae is made up of around
20 genera, which encompass around 250 known species.
And there’s a lot of variety in the Spathidiid
family to sort through.
For example, he largest species is about 35
times larger than the smallest.
And as far as shape goes, well, their name
is a callback to the origins of the word “spatula,”
and you can see that spatula shape in some of the species
when the broadness of its front end comes into view.
But that is not universal.
Some species are more round,
others more cylindrical.
And others take on shapes that require words
like “botuliform”
and “lunate” and “turbinate” to describe them.
And all Spathidiids are fairly flexible, which
helps them bend and wiggle around whatever
obstacle the microcosmos throws their way.
They can glide along mud particles, but in
water, they can also swim, by spinning around.
Some Spathidiids though put their flexibility
to work in other forms of movement, like this
species ducking in and out of the substrate
in motions that look more like a worm than
the spinning ciliate we saw earlier.
As diverse as Spathidiids are, there are a
few helpful features they all have in common.
One is that large circle you see at the back
of their body.
That’s the contractile vacuole, which helps
control the amount of fluid inside the organism.
As they swim through the water, the Spathidiids
accumulate water and other fluid in their bodies.
And while water is, you know, essential, if
there is too much, the Spathidiid will burst.
So to avoid that, watery explosion, they rely
on those large contractile vacuoles to gather
excess fluid and then expel it back out into
the world.
So in a way, what you’re looking at is the
Spathidiid equivalent of a bladder, taking
up a large amount of space so that the ciliate
can do its own version of peeing.
Spathidiids are colorless, but as you can
see here, they sometimes take on some green coloring.
That’s not their own pigments though—they
take on the verdant hue thanks to algae that
have either taken up residence as a symbiont,
or that have had the misfortune to be eaten.
In some cases, like with our Rhinothrix from
earlier, you can also see
bright, shimmering lights glowing from within.
Some of those are crystalline parts of the
organism, while others are sugars that refract
beautifully under our microscope’s light.
To hunt down their food, Spathidiids rely
on the toxicysts lining their mouths to immobilize their prey.
And from there, some species will swallow
their meals whole, while others use chemicals
released by their toxicysts to mash up their
meals outside their body,
like a little protist smoothie
they can just slurp up.
Now for all the distinctive traits of these
different species, they’re quite difficult
to identify by just looking at them
under a microscope.
Many of the traits that differentiate them
are subtle, rooted in features that don’t
immediately reveal themselves to us.
Instead, scientists have to turn to other
methods to bring those traits to light.
Take this species, for example, which we’re
pretty sure belongs to the genus Protospathidium.
One way for us to know for sure is to look
for a specific part unique to the genus, but
we can’t see it without killing the organisms
and adding stains that highlight that part.
So that’s why so much of our Spathidiid
footage is so vaguely labeled, it's hard to
figure out exactly what they are without killing
them, and we don’t really want to do that.
But that doesn’t mean we can’t enjoy digging
through their lives.
And there are a few species that we have been
able to identify a bit further, like this
moving ball of fuzz, which James is pretty
sure belongs to the genus Penardiella.
In fact, it might even be completely new.
When James first saw it under the microscope,
he thought it must be a damaged cell.
But he was shocked to find many more like
it on his slide, so now he’s collecting
more data to see whether or not it really
is a new species.
For comparison, this is another member of
the Penardiella genus that we think is Penardiella undulata.
If we’re correct, this would be the first
time someone has documented the species in
almost 90 years!
This species belongs to the genus Perispira,
but there’s not much known about it except
that its mouth spirals around its body, which
is definitely a helpful trait when it comes
to identifying the species.
And James is doing more molecular work with
this species to see if he can unravel more
of its mysteries.
But until then, the Spathidiids remain just
about as murky and opaque as the mud they
come from, though perhaps just a little bit
more beautiful to look at.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We’re going to be taking the next couple
of weeks off from uploading so we can catch
up on some stuff, but we will be back on March
28th with a brand new episode.
Before we go though, we want to say thank
you to Fabulous for sponsoring this episode.
Fabulous is an app that was created by behavioral
science researchers to gently support your personal goals.
Habit changing and habit building is hard.
So, if you’re looking for ways to add a
new thing to your routine,
Fabulous is the way to go.
Their Journey feature makes it easy to set
goals and track your progress using the roadmap.
With over 20 million users, Fabulous can help
you whether you’re looking for ways to stay
focused at work, need a reminder to take a
break once in a while to stretch and drink
some water, or if you’re looking to develop
a whole new post-work routine.
The app is 100% personalized to your goals
and with their daily coaching and goal setting,
you can start building your ideal daily routine!
The first 100 people who click on the link
in the description will get 25% off a Fabulous subscription.
We also of course need to say thank you to
all the names that are on the screen right now.
These are a bunch of human beings who wiggled
out of the mud one day and decided they wanted
to see some very peculiar kinds of content
on YouTube.com.
That content is the thing you are watching
right now, Journey to the Microcosmos, and
these are our patrons.
And I’m sorry that I said they wiggled out
of the mud, though I don’t think that they’d mind.
If you want to become one of our patrons on
Patreon, or maybe you’re thinking you might.
You can go to Patreon.com/JourneyToMicro.
We really appreciate everyone who supports
the channel.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss,
check out Jam and Germ on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.